Rick what were you going through
personally when you lost your arm I mean
did you ever doubt for a minute that you
wouldn't be able to play drums again
yeah I did it was horrible I did I just
want to disappear but then I found
really I found that the power of the
human spirit and the guys and my family
and everybody was just behind me it was
it was really special
is it true your drum kit weighs a
tremendous amount of weight because you
had a go and then reinvent the way you
play drums right it did the one I've got
now does yet why does the drum kit have
to waste so much more than a regular
drum kit I keep falling into it yeah
yeah he does it's just that I like it
set up exactly the same every night so
what they do is they they bolt it down
to this this this sort of steel plate
right that everything just travels as it
as it set up so every night they just
take the lid off the thing and and
sometimes they leave me in there but
it's a remarkable story in the human
spirit that you like at first you say
I'm never gonna play the drums again
[ __ ] it I'm never gonna go near a drum
kit after the accident and then at some
point do you say I'm gonna go try do you
you're absolutely I stop comparing
myself to how I used to play and I stop
comparing myself to others and I went
what I do is really unique go with that
Riley really how if it was such a weight
lifted and what point after the accident
do you go and sit down at a drum kit and
try to play the drums they said I'd be
in hospital for you know good six months
or whatever I got out within within a
month and then drove somebody drove me
straight to this place this guy Pete
Hartley he was building these pedals for
me so I went straight to his store sat
down for about three or four minutes
played the thing I was exhausted because
I you know obviously I'd been laid up in
bed and that was it it was like that
spark you left the hospital after a
month I mean you were supposed to be
there for six months yeah he went AWOL
that is crazy they said my recovery was
just really quick and for whatever
reason I
just everything worked out and like I
say I went straight headed straight for
the drum kit sat on the drum kit when
this is gonna work and then went home
and sort of slept for a week we stood a
40 seat belt that caused that because
you got thrown from the car
yeah the seat belt came out came undone
as I rolled the car I mean you're not
supposed to roll cars but a seat belt
came undone and it was the seat belt
that actually took my arm and the the
sunroof was open so I left through the
sunroof which in many ways could have
been a blessing I really don't know yeah
but I ended up in a field and this
district nurse she she found you yeah
she was in the car behind me how lucky
for you cuz you could have bled out and
died right that's you know one of those
angels on earth kind of stories you hear
if you're gonna be in a car accident
have a nurse make it okay
I heard the nurse ended up marrying the
doctor who operated it was actually
Roger and Eileen Pierce Roger was a cop
he was off to he and Eileen was that was
the nurse and you should be the priest I
know you should have married that lady
ended up being this wonderful love story
by you and you wrote that in a movie no
one would believe it no and you said
something that really is gonna I think
stay with me you said yeah you know what
I can't compare myself to whatever I
used to do I got to reinvent myself I
mean I still have moments of that like
wow
can i men can you imagine what I could
do if I had you know that what I used to
have but then I go you know what you
find
it's right everything's going fine yeah
the weird thing is he's been one old
longer than he was too on you know but
do you ever have that shadow experience
where you feel your arm yeah I can feel
the whole thing story about it oh yeah
sounds good it kind of had a mind of its
own it would sort of end up everywhere
and it just so happened that he ended up
going up somebody skirt I mean when they
figured there was like this presence
when I first lost my arm yeah was it was
like a physical presence she felt it
that's the thing really yeah wait a
second yeah wait are you being serious
yeah absolutely
you're saying you're in the hospital
yeah you lost your arm but yet you could
feel like it your arm was still there
there was it was like it was like the
static electricity was in the form of my
arm but I couldn't really control it you
know what I mean
and she said I feel something going up
my dress I said I said can you feel I
said I can't really control she said
with that withered with a really
interesting smile on her face she said
she said yes
Wow I don't know what to say about that
I know I know me neither I wish I still
had is like a sneaky make sure you
wallet zip do